[Musique]
à genève au salon telecom 99 l'industrie
mondiale de la téléphonie multiplie les
effets d'annoncé des démonstrations des
progrès en matière de télécommunications
avec ou sans fil avec ou sans musique
avec images ou adresse internet le
téléphone devient maintenant l'objet
centre du monde et promet nous dit-on
une civilisation nouvelle reportage
jean-claude allanic et claude sicard
demain c'est comme ça qu'on se
téléphonera le regard plongé dans son
portable
car grâce à une caméra on se parlera les
yeux dans les yeux
tenue correcte exigée surtout si votre
patron est au bout du fil
encore au stade du prototype le
téléphone caméra sera prêt dans deux ou
trois ans il permettra en toutes
circonstances de se voir et de tout voir
mais ce ne sera pas son seul intérêt en
passant par internet on pourra consulter
sur le téléphone un peu en ville ou
contactez un hôtel visiter les chambres
et faire la réservation si la chambre
boucle l'avenir du téléphone ce sera
aussi le commerce électronique relié à
un ordinateur il permettra d'entrer dans
un magasin virtuel et de dialoguer avec
une vendeuse bien réel l'expérience
pilote organisé par france télécom le
client est à genève
la vendeuse à nantes pour payer aux
passera évidemment par son téléphone
mais le futur très immédiat c'est ce
téléphone elite elle qui permet sans
avoir d'ordinateur à la maison de surfer
sur internet pour se connecter une
simple touche et vous êtes
sur le site de france 2 pour consulter
le minitel où on voyait du courrier
électronique aussi simple il suffit de
taper sur le clavier du téléphone
92 % des foyers français ne sont pas
connectés à l'internet et donc nous
essayons d'adressé la cible des gens qui
n'ont pas de pc aujourd'hui à la maison
et qui souhaitent néanmoins avoir accès
à des services sur internet ou sur
minitel présenté à genève ce téléphone
très branché sur internet sera en vente
dans quelques jours son prix 3990 france
[Musique]